e
excellent
good afternoon
everyone uh this month it is uh the
katakia to start us off um I was going
to do Tapo which is the one that we
learned uh in the far north but um this
one comes courtesy of Mark Patterson who
sent it through today I thought it was
fing so uh
ta here may peace upon us let us all
gather and go forward together please be
seated welcome everyone to our final uh
council meeting for the year um if you'd
like to know why I'm dressed up like
like this I was told I wasn't allowed to
wear the robes in the Santa parade cuz I
look too much like Santa so I thought it
would be fitting to wear it here for our
last council meeting here
today do we have any
apologies yes just councelor mcf Paul
mcf thank you for the councelor Richard
mcf cut up his have a move that we
receive that apology uh counselor
uh Stringer seconded by councelor mcell
all those in favor please say I and
against the motion is carried any
conflicts of interests in this agenda
today there appear to be none moving on
to the confirmation of minutes of the
ordinary council meeting held on the
21st of November
could I pleas have move that those are
true and
correct uh councelor Stringer seconded
by uh councelor Phillips all those in
favor please say I and against the
motion is carried confirmation of the
minutes assets and infrastructure
committee held on Tuesday the 28th of
November questions or
comments so move those minutes are true
and correct and the recommendations are
received got once Council Now seconded
by Council G I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried confirmation of
the minutes of the community well-being
meeting held on the 29th of
November questions or
comments have a
m oh do I have a comment Council
Fraser
just your microphone there can thank yes
sorry I clearly said the in the
agricultural sector and I highlighted
the the is businesses that I was working
in have do seem to be any theme in the
survey I just could be some change that
particularly around the agriculture
industry got that to
y happy thank you thank you coun
Fraser we get the mics turned down
slightly is that possible quite
loud I don't know how to do
that up the front back sit
back is that better we go cool fantastic
thank you council is uh are you happy to
move councel Fraser with that change uh
seconded by councelor Dixon
any further
comments all those in favor please say I
and against the motion is carried and
lastly the audit and risk committee
meeting held on Tuesday the 5th of
December any questions or
comments can I please have a m councelor
fail seconded by councelor
Mel I will put the motion all those in
favor please say I and against
the motion is
carried uh I've just been given a late
urgent item uh by the governance
manager uh so it says here his worship
to move that Pro to section 46 of the
Local Government Act information man act
the G Cil hereby resolved to address the
following uh which is an urgent action
this is to do with issuing a staff
warrant and
authorization uh the subject is the
staff warrant and authorization reason
for not being on the agenda is
information unavailable at the time of
the agenda being published and reason
for urgency as a new staff member uh to
be warranted upon commencement of
employment January 2024 could I please
have a move uh sorry I'm happy to move
uh seconder for that urgent uh councelor
Reed any comments on that I will put the
motion all those in favor please say I
and against the motion is carried and I
believe that is on the Hub at the moment
cool thanking you
so that will now become item 15 we'll
deal with that uh at the
end just before we get into item number
five I just wanted to do a quick little
speech from the from the chair um not
not prepared at all um just want to say
a huge huge thank you to uh counselors
around the table um for the effort that
they have put in this year um to the
community um it's been a it's been a
tough year for all of us uh cost a lot
in crisis um um we've we've definitely
hit our
she Shear of the news this year as well
so thank you for sticking with us I
really appreciate it um to those in the
uh the back who come to most of our
Council meetings really appreciate it um
thank you for coming along it's great to
see um faces here uh and uh I was going
to think the media but there doesn't
seem to be in you today um but yeah so
uh thank you to everyone for for
supporting us um this year um we're
really looking forward to to the next
next year um I just thought I would do
that at the front end um as I'm not too
sure how many people will make it to the
to the back end so um thank you very
much we to item number five uh New
Zealand Country Music Festival trust um
coming to a
presentation Jeff did you want to come
to the
stand thank Steve worship the mayor um
counselors um thank you for the
opportunity to come and
and share where where we have been and
where we are um so we're going to start
the presentation of technology is on our
side with a
video
[Music]
[Applause]
down
so a recap of uh very brief recap uh we
started tus country in uh
2020 after a group of like-minded uh
people from the different organizations
that had been uh integral in what
happens in what we call now King's
birthday
weekend and so B Tusk country was uh was
instigated and the first one was in 20
20 one planned for 20 but Co came along
and we've had two festivals that have
worked we've had 21 and
23 um it's grown to a 10-day Festival
over those two events and scheduled for
2024 over 70 events we want to
acknowledge the key players in that
obviously the G Count music Club New
Zealand MLT New Zealand gold guitar
Awards freeer bits off busing which uh
Jess has uh managed for us this past
year and the New Zealand songwriters
trust if we move to the
next which I really just covered off and
maybe the next one please thank you so
2023 from the data that we were able to
extract from uh surveys approximately
8,700 attendees 51% of them were from
outside of G they stayed an average of
3.6 nights and spent an average of $166
a day so the estimated economic return
of roughly 2 million to the easn
southern region um it's more of an art
not a science the surveys but it gives
us a good indication of just the impact
that the Su does that the the festival
does have on my left I'd like to
introduce you to Annabelle Roy Annabelle
is a marketing coordinator and she's
going to take you through the rest of of
this presentation thank you Jeff and
thank you all for
having
uh so it's my job to tell the story of
the festival uh and I've been on board
since
2021 we partner with uh local Regional
and National media to get the good word
out about Gore uh and all the things we
do down here we've been really fortunate
that New Zealand media does take an
interest in positive uh news stories uh
and over that 10day Festival this year
we were on breakfast news twice then you
could turn on again at night and see us
on the lotto um we were in in New
Zealand's Kora magazine uh and we're
also across the ditch uh at the Tamworth
music festival and all their print um
media as well so we're not only looking
at New Zealand but also an Australian
audience because they are a huge um
Market of country music fans as well um
I want to acknowledge the collaboration
we have with great South who do work on
our behalf as one of their um major
events and uh also to Jess for all the
work she does with us thank you
J uh um we have evolved we've we started
it with 40 odd events in
2021 when we had the year off in 2022 we
took the opportunity to add a whole lot
more in so last this year we had 60 odd
events for the festival focusing on not
just the music but also celebrating the
rural community that surrounds us and uh
developing the next generation of
musicians with a whole lot of workshops
and then some special interest things as
well so thank you to the mayor for
coming along and learning to make a
cheese roll
um we we had a lot of fun and we've
added a few more events this year um
we're taking the festival even to an
even broader Market um for uh all our
young and young at heart patrons we'll
be doing
um a show for preschoolers uh led by
Jeff
parsnips uh and then we'll also be doing
um some of the musicians who are coming
to Gore have pledged to go and visit uh
the Rest Homes the retirement homes
around Gore as well so they'll be
getting a taste of that too from the
comfort of their lazy boys sounds pretty
good to me um some big news we have this
year sorry last slid St apologies uh is
that last year we celebrated 50 years of
the um G country music club which is
such a founding pillar of this Festival
uh so there has been a documentary made
a feature length documentary on the 50
years of the gore country music Club
featuring some of their characters and
that is premiering uh in the festival
week this year at the St James Theater
so uh I really recommend getting along
to that there'll be a lot of faces
you'll recognize uh and it's a wonderful
celebration of some of the people who
have worked so hard in this community
for so long um we're also adding a few
more quirky things if you want to learn
how to make a cinnamon oyster with Carl
mccol you can go to that Workshop we're
not we're going to keep those skills
alive and uh we've seen some of the
counselor's dance moves in the last 24
hours so if your singing is as good as
you're dancing please come along to
karaoke and share that with the
world um thank
you uh we're
also always looking to mitigate barriers
to success and one of them is a
potential lack of accommodation for
visitors coming to gore not just
visitors but also participants in the uh
in gold guitars and things so last year
we started the um Tusa country home and
room rental scheme where locals open
their doors uh and hosted visitors it
was really successful most of the people
who came last year have booked again
with their hosts directly this year so
that's great uh for next year and then
we've just put it out again so already
we've got 94 additional bed nights and
that will uh per night um that will
increase a lot over the next few months
to really take that influx of people
coming in uh and lovely experiences like
Margaret here
uh who isn't just hosting them but she's
also expecting a bit of a show and she
would like a wine and I think staying
with Margaret sounds like a pretty good
time to me so um thank you to the people
of Gore who uh love this festival and
support this festival and also help host
our
visitors uh and these people the
volunteers the other event Community
groups uh and managers and of course our
sponsors and the gore District Council
Council thank you very much for
supporting our Festival uh it's a great
10 days and uh please take this as an
invite to come along in May and June
next year May 26th to June 3rd um and
get involved in the festival if you
haven't already it really is a whole lot
of fun and we're going to leave with
hopefully another video um this was put
together by our videographer his name is
Kellum he came down from Oakland really
sight unseen he didn't really know what
he was coming into but he spent 10 days
capturing the festival for us uh for
promotional purposes and this was a
little added extra he made at the end
he's called it a love letter to gore
because he had never experienced a small
community Vibe like he seen so uh this
is just celebrating all the people in
particular gold guitar's crew who um
made him feel so at home so thanks for
having us
today
[Music]
we you and me
dri
[Music]
suera
tears
and my
[Music]
love thank you very much uh Jeff and
anabal are you happy to answer questions
from the
back or the front or
yep Yeah question any questions from
counselors we made a long walk come on
councelor
re
thanks um thank you very much for the
presentation um I know how much work
you've all put into it um it's quite a
compliment to both of you uh Jeff as the
president and and also anab um I know
that you've come up with some most of
those quirky ideas where us other old
sticks in the mud don't think of them so
well done um really the best EX two
things out of that presentation um the
fact that we've had encouraged people to
stay longer and spend their money I
think that's amazing and of course the
other big thing is the lack of
accommodation and you targeted that very
well Annabelle so congratulations thank
you both very
much
thank you councelor any other questions
or
comments uh councilor
Phillips uh thank you your worship uh
just a great presentation guys and as
the chairperson of the grants committee
I just like to think that um you may be
in front of us again but uh it's a great
presentation and and we're doing a bit
of review on all the grants at the
current time so yeah so early in the new
year we'll probably see each other again
thanks very much for your presentation
tonight
thank you counselor any further
questions I just had one on
the uh accounts that you've given us I
just don't see the the grant that's gone
in from us here I may have missed it but
does that go into a different trust or
is that a how does that all work just
that a
curiosity
the role that Annabel has that the
council was funded for I think uh the
current timeline of that contract ends
the 25th of
January and then uh you may remember the
meeting I think April 18 um where we
came before you again and looked at
extending that and you've kindly agreed
to extend that on a sliding scale in
terms of the mechanics um I am unsure
what goes where
financially um so I'm not sure that I
can answer your question um I send a
fortnightly invoice was that what Happ
was I wish You' have said that first you
would have
said okay yeah no appreciate that guys
and I guess just on that sliding scale
um with the success of this event this
year you're comfortable with with that
flighting scale still a year a year long
you know Co has done a lot of damage to
us and other events as well um clearly
uh we are we are planning long to term
that we will be able to manage without
Council involvement later on um whether
we can pull that off or not only time
will tell to be quite honest there's so
many variables out there in the
environment right now so here we are um
but we're making every effort to to pull
that off so and um uh thank you to the
council for the support and your
continuing support um I'd like to think
we we will continue partnering with you
whatever happens down the line uh
because I think we we are all in each
other's pocket in making this place
great and can go destination so on
behalf of all of us I think we can wish
you all a merry
Christmas thank you very much for that
and really really appreciate uh the
honesty uh was there any further
question sorry
kie just a comment from my from my um
you're doing a fantastic job of
promoting our town and long may it
continue If eventually it can stand on
its own feet it's a beautiful young lady
out there representing everybody and
doing such a fantastic
job um but I yeah I just want to say job
well done CU it's putting this town on
the map for all the right
reasons thank
you thank you for that counselor and I
yeah just like to second that thank you
very much for for taking me into your um
little world over over those 10 days um
and I look forward to do it all over
again next year as well so um thank you
very much for your presentation really
appreciate
it
did we have any further discussion or
are we happy to move
on happy to move on could I pleas have a
move that this information has received
Council second by councelor Stringer I
put the motion all those in favor please
say I and against the motion is carried
thank you very
much item number six uh three Waters
capital investment requirements and the
impacts of government's plans to repeal
the three Waters reform met really this
close to Christmas on such bad news uh
did you want to add anything to the
report thank you worship um no I don't
think I have anything um to add to the
report but more than happy to take any
questions thank you I guess for uh and
the chief executive might be able to
help me out here but U just for uh the
public uh we have recently received a
letter from the minister uh around uh
three Waters and what we need to be
doing uh so the indication from uh the
new government is to put uh three Waters
back into our long-term plan so we're
working through the motions of doing
that now um as as challenging as that
may be uh as well as there is an option
for smaller rural councils who need it
um to uh extend the ltp out to uh the
30th of September 2024 if they need it
uh this Council will still be aiming for
the 1st of July um but it is comforting
to know that the new government is
listening to us um and has given given
that three month bus buffer um while it
isn't the the one year or three years
that we're originally going for um 3
months is is better than
nothing now open the floor to debate do
we have any questions for Matt on this
report uh councelor guard
IR just more of a statement than a
question to M interesting I'll put the
number of the rate increase for um water
uses going from
$1,340 and 28 years to $
6,770 that's an annual increase of 5.8%
on a compounding rate so it's
interesting it probably doesn't look
affordable but if you go backwards 25
years you'll probably find the right
right value was a lot less than it is
today and the same thing about 400%
because it there's an annual increase
with you like it or not it's 5 or
6% um but just looking at the
affordability on my feeling the if we
have to continue the work on on the
three Waters ourselves and not have any
help from government you'd have to
extend that time frame to 60
years to be able to afford
it thank you councelor I guess the and
correct me if I'm wrong here Mt that
would be 5 was it 6% but that's only for
the for the water side of things so
youve still got the other the rest of
our business that you'd have to add on
to that so You' probably be looking at
Double Double percent rate increases for
the next 30 years if if that was the
case no no if you work on the numbers M
showed us$ 1340 for um the increase from
the current $1,300 goes to
$677 that's a 5.8% per year but over the
28 years it's a 400% increase that's for
your whole three water package
right thank you Cel it's good any
further comments from counselors
questions uh councelor Stringer and then
coun
F through
um does that amount your including um
allow
for the the cost of the infrastructure
increas in that time as well so there's
going to be an added expense in that and
your inflation as well on top of it so
um obviously that you're near half a
billion dollars in over 30 years
time Council
MF yes just through worship probably um
the other counselors have touched on it
anyway was just uh what councelor
Stringer was saying in regard to
we're looking ahead 30 years at half a
billion dollars worth of Deb so um it
would be interesting to have a crystal
wall and it's um interesting the
recommendation actually states that it's
a highlight uh highlighting the funding
challenges it's almost highlighting the
funding and possibilities um because
sure as hell we we can't do anything
other than uh go to central government
so um it's a pretty hard situation
really to face um particularly when we
look ahead 30 years and there probably
some of us may not be here or looking
ahead for the town itself um the major
issue that we struck struck with water
so uh the pace the government's going at
the moment with changes it'll be
interesting to see what change they can
do um we obviously have had some uh a
small one in regard to the long-term
plan but um yeah I think it's more than
a funding challenge I think it's almost
a funding imp
possibility yeah good point well said uh
any other
questions uh Council McKenzie and
Council
MD I'd just like to comment on what you
said Richard what happens when you run
out of money and you can't do these
things what physically
happens that's the biggest question of
all isn't it we haven't got enough money
to do what we're being told to do so
what happens
then
Steve
uh through your worship well it's a very
good point because we have debt
covenants so we have we're sealing on
our debt and that has been designed to
uh ensure
affordability and so we will rapidly hit
those like many other councils those
those limits in coming years and so what
that means in terms of how we project
our financials of the next 10 years if
we can foresee that we'll breach our
debt covenants within three or four five
years of that and how that looks to
audit I don't know but a lot of councils
will be in the same category this goes
the heart of I think is a conversation
that central government uh both the
previous government and this government
doesn't want to have which is we've got
a national infrastructural problem here
we need National help and no amount of
fiddling while R Burns and creating
different uh vehicles and ccos it's
still going to result in a very high
bill being sent to the
consumer and um a bit like the the poor
lonely person in the Dance Floor uh
Wasing to dance with someone that's
local government central government got
their dance Partners their cards fall
and saying we'll ignore you but
council's up and down new Z now saying
we need financial
help so sorry Council I don't have any
other options than
that
un fortunately I don't have any extra
money uh councelor mcdonal and councelor
Fraser I I agree with what the chief
executive said I think the thing is
there going to two things going to have
to happen in the long term is there's
going to have to be some government
funding as well as we're going to have
to stretch this stuff out to 50 to 60
years and just try and do what we can do
to keep things running CU there's no way
we can we got the debt sealing and also
the interest costs and we just wouldn't
be able to afford afford
them councel presid you you worship um I
totally agree with what Steve said and I
think people need to realize that no
matter which entity it's under the rate
payer or the taxpayer will be paying for
it and but the the biggest problem that
we're going to have is that somewhere
there will be a catastrophic failure and
where is the funding is it central
government's going to come in to help
protect it or is it the rate pay so it
is it's you get a lot of councilors are
carrying this Queen will be a classic at
the moment is how are they going to
afford to fix their
problems I think an interesting point on
sorry to interrupt an interesting point
on that as well with the the queen Town
situation is that when you do have a
catastrophic like that and they do Mass
improvements all at once that means that
everyone else around the country when
those regulations come up we have to
wait um and that's the case we got the
moment luckily we're in a fortunate
position where all we have to do is a
pipeline under the river but all those
councils have to do UV treatment are
going to have to wait in line um and
those regulations as we know are coming
thick and fast uh
Jason uh thank you worship um just on a
couple of comments around you know
stretching things out 50 to 60 years we
don't have that Liberty um and you know
I guess councils in the past have been
stretching and kicking the can and
sweating assets already so the
stretching out further um comes back to
the comment around you'll just have a
number of um you know big blowups with
that's you know that's what we're trying
to avoid here so the planning is there
we know that the assets are only going
to last a certain amount of time and
this is the um the planning that goes
into trying to make sure that we don't
have those issues going forward but
that's the challenge for us that we
face thank you Jason any other questions
or
comments just on the uh storm water
separations work um I can see that the
the other bill are going to be kind of
forced upon us um in some regard and
obviously don't want um uh overflow of
storm water to continue but is it
something that will be regulated
something that will be forced to have to
increase um that that storm water
separation
and through worship yeah so yeah the
regulation around that is coming um I
guess in sort of two areas one being our
Wastewater discharges so with our um
combined system when we get rainfall we
get really high flows through our
wastewater treatment plant which affects
our performance and and the volume and
and loading that we discharge through
our wastewater treatment plant so with
our renewed consent potentially we'll
get um tighter limits there that we need
to meet um and the other thing is um
with South's new Landing water plan um
becoming fully operative potentially in
the next 12 months um it's likely that
we're going to have to get um consent
around
um uh overflows from our Wastewater
system under heavy rain events um and
the only way we can resolve that is to
get the storm water out of our
Wastewater system U for our
separation thank you for that P not a
not a pretty
picture any other questions comments
from counselors
so the recommendation of stand is that
the port we received uh the council note
the estimated 465 million capital
investment in three Waters of the next
30 Years uh and that the council write
to the government highlighting the
funding challenges requesting a
potential a meeting to potenti uh
different funding
mechanisms is everyone comfortable with
that approach I'm kind of
I said on the fence with the the lead
requesting a meeting while I agree with
it I don't know how much effect it will
have with this new government trying to
get its feet under the table uh and
wonder whether it's better to to work
with our surrounding neighbors to to get
that attention I'm not sure um I kind of
just be a bit of feedback uh councelor
Dixon thank you
worship um I'm just feeling with 6 and a
half thousand rate payers is that um
it's just insurmountable to ask us to
pay that
money um to fund this and I I do
actually think we possibly should think
of joining other councils it's just my
thought about
that it's a bit more of a unified
approach towards um central government I
guess to put some context around my
thinking um we've had conversations with
uh we became inity J um when the
president previous government changed
everything um and that was a real
struggle for us uh because we lose uh
the likes of CH who has a huge rate
payer base um and is able to subsidize
um us down here um other than den and M
there's not really large mass areas that
have a whole lot of rate payers to to
pay these large infrastructure costs so
um unless we have some serious funding
from central government we were all
struggling to see kind of how how we
were going to keep a flight Council
thank you your
worship I favor an individual approach
to government primarily because we are
one of the smaller local councils but we
have one of the bigger problems in terms
of our waste water in storm water I
understand we have one of the highest
proportions um nationally um so we have
a unique issue here and unique issues
tend to get lost when you are working
together with others I do encourage
working together with others but I think
we need to be independent and promoting
our particular circumstances so it's
drawn to the government's
attention thank you for that counselor
uh again just uh just feeding back
meetings that myself and the chief
executive have had um there seems to be
a real split of either I agree and
correct me if I'm wrong Steve but um
that we are the only one who has the
real problem with the separation but um
there are counselors who are even
dealing with waste water as their
primary problem or fresh water so we're
very privileged to be in the situation
where fresh water isn't the massive
issue waste water is but it seems to be
like they're grouped into either it's
one set of waters or or the other B of
the real issue councelor
re you Mr Mayor I'm with councelor Havel
on this one um I'd be interested to hear
what the chief executive thinks but um
sometimes our voice gets lost um amongst
the rest of the um noise so I'd like to
see us stay
independent thank you councelor did you
want to jump on it
to yeah thanks you wishop um I think
yeah like it's um I tend to favor the
individual track but still remaining
linked with your your Council neighbors
so that sometimes when you do go with
your neighbors it's great but sometimes
it can be a little bit
the voice can be a bit more Tamer and
bit bit bit more polite uh and sometimes
you need to be a bit more pointed um and
uh I think there's lots of discussions
going on across the country try people
trying to remain in in um constant with
each other but also the um qualification
that we need to be having at times an
independent view so I I tend to come
down on the look um we be better off uh
advancing our own concerns directly with
central government but that's not to say
that we would not still work with uh uh
Kindred Spirits other councils uh
because this is a conversation that's
not going to go away and um the council
Fraser said and and Council McKenzie
what when you get to a failure and
failure what does failure look like it
looks like you know like for example
Wellington in terms of its uh structure
I've heard SS like a symphony of
eruptions um yes where where they just
literally uh fail without notice because
the infrastructure has reached the end
of its life um and we saw a little peep
into that future with Wigan Street in
the 2020 floods uh and we've Since U
rectified that but you still wonder what
other types of wi streets are out there
in our district that could could fail so
um
this is an urgent issue and um i'
probably you favor having some sort
direct line of um advancement to central
government but not it shouldn't be your
only bullet in the holster you should be
using other as say kindred spirit
councils to advance the
cause thank you for that Steve and and
thank you councilors for that feedback
and that discussion it was very uh
valuable uh if there isn't any contary
use on that approach uh may I suggest
that we change the recommendations
slightly um to council hov's Point uh
including a part about so highlighting
its funding challenges um and the
uniqueness of our storm water separation
just recognizing that um what met was
saying around um this requirement is
coming and it's coming fast um I have a
funny feeling we get stuck with that
$250 million bill sooner rather than
later um where it's it's going to be be
a requirement so it might be worth
flagging that to um central government
as a as a priority and it might make us
Stand Out above the heat his Council
read was was
suggesting some like a fear
recommendation did we get some form of
that y yep cool um I'm actually happy to
move that from the chair um do I have a
seconder council read any further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you Matt for
your work on that really appreciate
it uh item number seven the youth
Council uh
review uh did you want to speak on this
as an's not here yeah thanks you worship
uh unfortunately an P's uh not well so
she's not with us today uh but I've been
involved in this process uh within in
regard to the youth Council review it
was something that she was Keen to
advance at least to uh critically
examine how the council youth council is
structured how it's performing and is it
in line with expectations and hence the
commissioning report from M Consulting
Rebecca M um Rebecca's come down with
two clear options I guess the first
thing to acknowledge is that the council
the youth Council current guys has
strayed away from its original purpose
um and also has uh constructed itself a
little differently from what it was at
the outset um at the outset the youth
Council was the primary vehicle for to
show to give leadership opportunities
for senior Secondary School students and
to provide a voice for youth around the
council table based on gender items of
the day and and probably over the
past eight or so years uh over since the
youth Council was uh conceived in
2007 uh the that purpose has moved away
more to um events for youth with a far
more broader range of participants um it
has over the years and with the benefit
of being in the saddle in this job for
quite some time I've seen again the
sometimes the scrambling to just get a
resource around the youth Council to
support it and its Endeavors and on
balance staff thought maybe it's time to
draw a line in the sand and say it's
it's run its course but like a lot of
other lot initiatives um there perhaps
another way to still um seek uh and hear
that youth voice but that's just a staff
recommendation this is ultimately a
political decision and what we want to
make sure though is that if you want to
see the youth Council
reinvigorated uh it will need to be
adequately resourced and hence we have a
figure in the report so you're aware of
what that resourcing requirement
is thank you for that Steve counselors
uh councelor Reed thank you Mr May um
I'd just like before I start I'd like to
acknowledge that we do have um a current
youth counselor in the room Matthew
Clinton along with his mother Rebecca um
and I really want to see the youth
Council continue how can we not continue
if that requires a rethink and a
restructure so be it and as a society we
tend to criticize young people for not
voting but Civics are not taught in our
schools and the youth council is a way
for those interested to be encouraged to
use their voice for the
community it may not be every teenager's
dream of a fun time out but unless we
give a revitalized youth Council the
opportunity to find their feet we won't
know and as I've said before um the fact
that this current term of council has
seen no counselor appointed is quite a
disappointment to
me and I would encourage elected members
to think about how they vote and what
message they're sending to our youth
let's give a restructured youth Council
a chance to encourage young people of
the district to learn and participate in
local government democracy it may not be
successful but if we are Duty I think we
are Duty bound to allow them the
opportunity to make that revitalized
youth Council work and finally I'd just
like to say that when I was the council
W for 3 years over that time I saw many
fine young people go on to become
responsible and active members of our
communities and other communities
outside of the district some Sayed local
some are scattered throughout New
Zealand and over the world they have
become firefighters volunteers Builders
Engineers paramedics and students our
community that allows them to learn and
grow will always share the opportunities
to welcome them
home I hope that councils at this table
vote for the restructure and allow the
guidelines in the report to be set up
with under guidance thank
you thank you very much counselor
Council Havel and then Council
McKenzie in my view we have planned for
the Youth Council to
faade we at a councelor level have not
engaged with it nor have we adequately
resourced
it how many councilors around the table
in the current term have actually been
to a youth council
meeting why don't we have we have a
counselor who attends youth Council
meetings when I was putting together
with other counselors the list of uh
representation on different groups of
council no one was prepared to put their
hand up to actually attend the meetings
and I think that is quite an appalling
situation because we should be engaging
with the young we should
be encouraging their
input and working together with them
they have a view it's an important View
and it's a view that if nurtured at a
younger age will actually be of benefit
to The Wider Community as we move
through many of the children or the
young people who are on the youth
Council are the Future Leaders not only
in this community but elsewhere when you
look at the success that some of them
have had and I've had contact with in in
previous years I agreed the structures
wrong the way probably the age group is
is is
incorrect and I also have doubts that
the process that we have followed for
selecting people on the youth council is
probably not uh as dynamic as it should
be as
well is the council actually providing
sufficient information of what the
expectation is of what is going to
happen on the youth Council uh people
going on fully understanding of of what
is required
I believe we do need to go back to First
principles but I see the youth Council
as an important arm of not only the way
that we carry out our governance
functions but also the way that we
interact with the wider Community just
because there's an individual at the
table on the youth Council tends to
overlook the context they've got at
schools and the way that they're
actually able to influence back through
the
community so in terms of the
recommendations that we've got I'd
actually like to remove uh to move that
the report be received and that is the
only motion put
forward thank
you thank you councilor hob and happy to
second that councelor
read can we not have it is not the only
motion put forward is that right we able
to kick around a different different
motion but each I have only moved the
one motion therefore in terms of
standing orders it's been uh accepted um
there is the ability for someone to move
an amendment but whether an amendment
can be done in the context of that is
probably something for the chief
executive to comment on I I think we'll
proceed with the uh the report we
received once that uh either pass are
failed then we can Circle back to if
there's any more motions around might be
a bit of a cleaner process
there uh thank you both uh I just wanted
to before we move on on to council
McKenzie I just wanted to clarify um
because it doesn't seem to be known but
uh when we were initially setting up
committees and appointments uh councelor
Paul mcf um put up his hand and was very
keen to uh be the one appointed to the
youth Council um however due to the
review being undertaken um it was
advised that we don't have a
representative on there so that the
review could could um be completed uh
before adding a counselor permanently is
to hope that clarifies a little bit
councelor
McKenzie through your worship um as
obviously before I used to have dealings
with the youth Council wearing my other
hat some time ago and they were a bunch
of really
enthusiastic young people they used to
come and Alex used to organize them to
come in and talk live on the radio with
me I think we need to see is there um
the
enthusiasm not from just one or two
people
but is the the enthusiasm there to be
part of a youth Council and if we decide
to rejig it can we not put a time frame
on it to say let's look at it again in 6
months or something that's just an
example just just just a comment you
know if we do decide to rejig it um
let's say we'll put some sort of time
frame on it on it and say okay is this
working or not and give the youth counil
a chance to prove themselves for want of
a better
term thank
you thank you Council McKinley Council
Dixon thank you
worship I think that youth actually need
a voice as this generation is making
decisions for the future generations and
it's not just around policy and
economics but I think it's regarding the
legacy of Youth that that um that the
decisions that we are making in and they
will
inherit I also think the wisdom of
Elders and the innovation of our youth
is a good mix and I'd like to see youth
Council retained but maybe in a a
different way um which would be project
targeted I think um youth have a lot to
add to our district plans and a
long-term plan with their ideas and
ideals and their Innovative thoughts and
I also wonder if um if we're going to
retain youth Council then it needs to be
resourced maybe better and perhaps we
should look at the ministry of Youth
Development there is a fund there that
that could help with that so I would
like to see it retained and um I would
also like to support
what councelor HOV and councelor Reed
have said as
well thank you councelor councelor
Fraser thank you wor ship um I'll go
against the trend slightly in its
current form it's just not working um I
don't agree with the age range and I'll
put another hat on in a previous life
I've worked with a lot of Youth um you
have a minority a very small minority to
want to do something I believe there
needs to be a transition into a targeted
model as you were talking about Council
Dixon I agree but currently let be
perfectly honest it is not working so
something else needs to be done if you
want to keep the youth
involved thank you
councelor any further comments on the
motion on the
table uh councilor
Phillips thank you wishop now I'm in
agreeance with other counselors and I
believe that us as a coun counselors
went to sleep on this issue and I
apologize for that for the to the um the
youth Council
and I believe that we should be
retaining them um perhaps restructure
and
funding um I know I know our budgets are
really tight at the moment but I think
it's essential
that we the youth are are a up and
cominging counselors and um if we don't
show them the way and and how to do it
for the future then they're lost as well
so and I I'm I'm in agreeance with the
rest of the
council thank you councelor councelor
Reed thank you um a couple of things
around the age
um I bow to your Superior knowledge but
um the other thing is too um I'm looking
at Matthew sitting in the room and I
think um your second year
Matthew and you are
13 yeah
um Matthew is a bright articulate young
man we cannot always say that um an age
makes a difference and I'm first to
admit that um but the other thing is too
is that sometimes when the kids get a
bit older um they actually lose focus
other things become
priorities and I well remember being
16 and believe you me it isn't being on
the youth Council so there is a fine
point and I think when um those review
proc proces are happening we need to be
very um aware that there is a fine line
between early engagement and expecting
to to move off at the other
end thank you
councelor well made
points any further discussion on this
motion uh then we'll we'll put it and
then we'll Circle back to some of the
other conversation that's been happening
uh
councelor I'd like to exercise my right
of
reply and I think there has been a
strong message that have come from
counselors in terms of the desirability
of retaining the youth Council and the
um motion that that I've put forward
this the report will be noted um will
therefore as a coroller that does not
need to be part of the um um Rec
recommendation is is that a further
report will need to come to Council in
terms of uh funding through the
long-term plan um but also um a
framework for moving forward and and
given that the youth council is replaced
each year at something that will need to
happen at our next meeting I I would
like to see um as part of the youth
Council some of the things that are
picked up
elsewhere um such as the me me mentoring
um the the chairperson of the youth
councils and council is actually
actively engaging in some of the um
meetings of of the youth Council um
while there's some desirability as
councelor Dixon said of having targeted
um issues for them to look at um I'm a
bit reluctant to actually say just this
and this I think uh we need to create a
framework be whereby um the youth are
encouraged to actually
identify um some issues important to
them as well as to respond to the issues
that are before the council um what
reports go from Council to the youth
Council what reports go from the youth
Council back to the council so the
interconnectedness between um the two
levels as it were um is is something
that if we strengthen that I think we
can end up with a body that is actually
making a very valuable contribution
thank
you thank you C answer and I like the
idea of uh that that mental mentee um
and I say that with the two-year program
that I'm currently involved and so um
had an awesome young man uh named tan
who uh we worked as that Mentor mentee
uh this year um but we are considering
whether we do two year next year so um
that that could be a key consideration
with the I we'll end the debate there
and put this put this motion so all
those in favor please say
I and in the motion is
carried now for what's been kick kicked
around a little bit um is well there's
another recommendation there about a Way
Forward um just recognizing and I think
we talked about this at a workshop but
recognizing that uh the the current
budget is 5 5,000 for the Youth Council
uh and as councilor Fraser said the
current structure isn't isn't working so
I wonder whether there is an appetite
from counselors to put a pause on the
youth Council for uh 2024 considering
the budget isn't there the budgeting
won't come in until the ltp is finalized
um so even if we increase the budget it
won't be till halfway through the year
so that the youth Council will be
underfunded for that first half of the
year that also gives time to involve uh
the current youth Council who uh is a
fantastic youth councel got to spend uh
the evening ice skating with them which
was good fun uh very intelligent and
also um has that youthfulness and
actually have them help design uh and
workshop through what the new what the
new youth Council looks like um as I
wrote an email earlier today uh it would
be designed by youth for youth uh so
that in 2025 we can do formal elections
with it properly budgeted uh and move
forward from there so really spending
the year reconstructing it uh and then
moving forward from there did I have any
contrary views I'm just looking for a
bit of a Way Forward councelor
hell
yes I have a contrary view think of Co
the way stuff stopped for 6 months year
and the ability for it to pick up again
is very slow and
sluggish um I don't believe you can set
something up for starting in the middle
of the year the first three months or so
of the youth council is actually
organizing themselves and working out
where they are where they sit what the
issues are that that are important um in
the same way that us as a council are
constrained at times uh in terms of we
can't spend money until it's been
approved as part of the long-term plan
or the annual plan the youth Council
faces the the same issue they can't
start spending money until it's been
approved by the appropriate process but
money is just one side of it a lot
um there is a staff resource that that
requires funds to be dedicated to it but
not um money by itself and um
uh I think that the um activities of the
youth Council that don't incur
additional costs Beyond staff time and
Beyond the time that I believe
councilors also need and the M need to
be putting into it is is something that
we shouldn't put a hold on we need to
keep the momentum or develop the
momentum again um so I'm opposed to the
idea of deferring it for one year or
even for six
months thank you councelor uh just in
response that um that first three months
of organizing themselves I think is
probably the most challenging part
because it's been a whole lot of Staff
time has to be dedicated to helping out
the youth Council helping them get set
up um and as this report clearly states
uh 5 hours a week is is not enough to do
that um I also have concerns um pulling
that the money is all around staff time
so I I have issues pulling staff time
away from other projects in those first
couple of months to help the youth
Council and then somehow paying it back
at the end of the year it's just to to
council phras this point before I don't
kind of want this this youth Cil to
continue without the resources and the
support there um until we can actually
formalize proper hours around um that
position hopefully that makes a little
bit more
sense do we have any other views around
the table everyone's kind of
processing Council Phillips
I think you
this mics are not very good
today um what one of the options in
there was to revitalize restructure the
G use Council and align up with us an
original purpose of representing the
youth voices to Le a with Council what's
missing there is the funding um and I
think I think we can work away on their
funding like why get why get bogged down
with the issue of funding when actually
they may only need the 5,000 that we
already represented for the for the
first three six to six months um yes
they may be restrained for the funding
but it's the
fundamental changes that we that we
would
want not so much the funding as such and
let us get work ahead to get the funding
together because if we lose this lose
the first year we're going to lose it
together because it's going to take
another 6 months to get everybody back
together and the great opportunity that
we have is that mway college coming
together for the first
time in the new year is a great
opportunity for us to get there and
handpick quite a lot of people all one
one one hit
so I think you know just um just F
thought on that one that we just perhaps
just think about is the funding
necessary for the first three
months yeah I think it comes a valid
point I guess sorry sorry interrupt um
the next speakers I guess I'm stting to
wrap my hand around how we restructure
it while we're also getting coun like
we're forming a new youth Council doing
elections everything like that I'm just
trying to think through time frames so I
could get some more clarity on that
councelor re and councelor
Mel yes thank you um further to um
councelor Phillips's comment I think
um maybe for this next term next 12
months or whatever we how hard is it to
extend the meetings instead of meeting
every month make it every six weeks um
there's plenty of things that they can
do in the interim to actually look at
what they're going to be doing in the
next 12 months um planning um like
volunteer work um things that they can
do without any cost to themselves or to
the council I don't think um it's it to
me it just shouldn't be an
issue but I'm Happ to take Direction on
that from the chief executive you're
looking a bit poised for
Action yeah I'll let number and then and
circle back to
St question is the chief executive do we
have a staff person on the council on
the staff president who's DED got any
time dedicated to the youth
Council through um your worship not
really I mean not in terms of the
desired amount of ours that we' need
it's it's been just uh assigning who's
available to do the job they can to
support the youth Council uh so and cing
back to council Reeds um suggestion look
we can do whatever the council want I
mean we can
um if my suggestion really fundamentally
is you either resolve to retain the
council and given the I appreciate his
worships comments around well we're
trying to figure out what is the
structure and the funding what have you
my suggestion would be that if you
retain the
council um that uh you just carry on as
you uh in the interim knowing that on
overlaid with that will be a new
structure with some appropriate
resourcing but it's likely to be coming
into effect uh in the 25 calendar year
uh or be at the the resourcing May will
arrive in mid 24 if it's all approved uh
but I think it would
be might be possible but to actually by
time you actually talk to the the youth
counselors come up with a structure have
it actually teased out have it approved
by the council you're probably going to
find a couple of months um be eroded
into the new year and it may well be
that um then you've got to actually go
and actually fill those positions in
terms of the new structure so off the
top of my head it might pay you to just
proceed with planning for a new Council
in 24 based on the old structure knowing
that it's going to morph into a new one
um in the following 12
months thank you for that Steve I think
I think Council reads actually RIS a
really interesting point about whether
we could keep it as it is now with the
existing structure as as the CH could
have said but maybe one of the key tasks
is helping us with the the redesign for
the 2025 as one of their primary tasks
um moving forward and then obviously
supporting them a bit better than we did
this year um with with key projects but
that is their their primary focus is to
um re reshuffle it for for 2025 and also
I mean it's a great lobbying opportunity
as well for the ltp and things of EXP
explaining what resources they need
moving forward and understanding the
buds that we have to go through I think
that's a I think it's a great great way
to keep momentum going councelor Fraser
and then councelor bre thank you your
worship look I'm not adverse to that
myself but there needs to be changed has
to be set and clear that this be changed
with the date when they need to come
forward you know we can't morph into
next year and then forget about it again
it can't get to that point and then
we're back here A year later having the
same arguments um so there needs to be
some clear Direction about how that
happened happy with that counc uh
Council
mcf yes just re worship
um within that recommendation within the
report it actually indicates what the
recommendations are to actually re
restructure the council so we we're not
going round and around discussing
something that's would have been
recommended there like um
we're sort of indicating that if we if
we advance to where we're going amongst
the discussion there's obviously support
here but the recommendations there
clearly outline how the council can be
vitalized so it's already been planned
out that could be given to the new youth
Council and they work on it's page four
of that report page four and five um if
you're going with option one it has the
recommendations already
listed so I I'm just wonder whether
we're don't try and reinvent the wheel
it's actually sitting there in black and
white um but I think clearly the uh
listening to other councils I support
the fact that um you know we we do need
to um probably with the youth Council
has been a bit of collateral damage
really over the last couple of years we
we've let it slide so we do need to
support it there and there's clearly um
uh options available to us quite simple
recommendation here option one move
forward and the new Council works on
it can
be councelor
Phillips yeah that that's what I read
out before the only thing that's missing
is the funding and if we just carry on
with what we're doing at the moment we
can talk about the funding later on so
let's just let's be moved and
seconded so just just the clarification
so with the recommendation you're
wanting
to enact these recommendations here for
the next application of the youth
Council 2024 so that includes uh
lowering the age limit from year 9 to
year 11 um all these recommendations out
listed here um I'm just checking other
than the other than the funding which we
wouldn't be able to do till the
ltp Council H coun yeah Council and
Council
Phillips my understanding is that um so
we we've got a motion that in the fix is
that the council Revitalize and
restructure Etc I don't believe it needs
anything
else uh in its simplest form there are
some ideas there that actually need to
be worked through uh in part with the
youth Council and in part with um
Council staff and we don't need to get
into the nitty-gritty I think it's an
overall position that would Revitalize
and restructure in in its simple
terms councelor Phillips thank you
worship and I agreeance with Council H
the thing is that we went to sleep and
I'm to blame because I'm a council that
went to sleep on this
issue but the options as it reads is
Revitalize and restructure the go
District Council Youth and align it with
its original purpose of representing
youth voices and the with the council
that's all we need at the moment we can
add the funding later
I I appreciate I appreciate the motion
that stands I guess I'm I'm just trying
to help out our staffs staff a little
bit as to what are the next steps
because it's it's very well doing this
high level analysis of this is what we
want but I I struggle to see kind of
what what the next steps are there's
there's a whole lot of work workshopping
etc that needs to go into this we need
to either bring on board a new youth
youth Council and what requirements
there's just a quite a few things to to
sit out I don't feel like we're giving
great guidance to the staff here is the
intention to leave it over to the staff
as to what the interpretation of that
recommendation is Council
Philips no absolutely
not the intention is that the council as
as as all of us and the youth Council be
together and United about what we want
to do and restructure itself if it means
that we're going to have
workshops this sound system is
absolutely terrible
today
um if it means that the council itself
and the count youth Council get together
in workshops work out what they want
work out how to how to do things what
went right what went wrong everything's
listed here it's been it's a great
report everything that's in there that
we need to restructure for is in that
report let's work through it
together and I think there's a staff
member that's willing to stand up and
help out let then I think the chief
executive might be able to find some
times
over okay so do we want to add to that
then a workshop to be had in the new
year is a Way Forward no we don't need
it let's actually give the staff the um
intelligence that they have on terms
terms of uh that's the position we're
adopting it is the staff's
responsibility to implement it and we
don't need to spit out set out the a b
and c of what needs to be
done and we will have a further report
and if if they want to have a workshop
and share with us and if we were to have
a workshop I'd actually want to have the
You Youth there as well um so let the
staff go away and actually think about
the a BS and C's and and um uh take it
from there we're trying to get into too
much Det tell you wish we don't need
to I concur but there is a um there is a
motion in a second so I'm sorry mover in
a second so um we do need to move on uh
do we have any further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried
thanks moving on to item eight uh sister
city protocol Tim withth and Gore
District uh did Steve want to speak to
this one pretty
straightforward uh any other comments or
questions from the floor uh councelor
Dixon thank you worship um I just wanted
to say that it seems that we have a far
lot more in common with Tamworth than
just music and I'd like to see it
extended a little bit into it because
we've got agricultur sport Arts
Parks um it we could expand that
relationship more than just in country
music thank you Council it's so it's a
great suggestion councelor
McKenzie um part of the process has been
teeing up interviews we we've done one
um we interviewed a member of the
timworth
Council on ear think you were there did
you join in on that one
and we're in the process of promoting
what else you can do in our towns as
well as music festivals and things like
that weren't we that that was our plan
to Let's promote what you can do in G as
well as tset country Etc and and and the
same in Tamworth what can you do there
so we did one interview and we talked
about the things you can do in Tamworth
as well as the music festival and um
we're going to tea up yourself and the
for an interview sometime as well and we
want this to be a two-way street so that
they can interview us about the things
you can do in Gore in surrounding
districts as well as the music festival
I just wanted to add those comments on
there it's just something that we're
working on quietly thank
you thank you for that update
counselor any further comments councelor
Fraser
thank you um I sat here and wonder
sister city you know what is in it for
what is in it for Gore because
regardless whether you get a assist any
agreement with them the gore go Tower
one is going there anyway um it it's to
me it's a lot of money spent on a very
few amount of people having nice trucks
over there and it returned coming back
um I'm not actually supportive of it um
never have been a sister city it's just
a comment
thank you councelor for your
assessment any other
comments if there's no more comments
could I have a mover for this
recommendation uh councelor mcf seconded
by uh councilor Phillips any further
discussion this goes
forward uh councel Phillips thank you I
just that I like councel Dixon's idea of
U expanding the horizons of what can be
done in 10th and what can be done in the
G district and I think that we should be
promoting that as
well thank you
councelor no further discussion I will
put the motion all those in favor please
say I and again
would you like to record it y uh the
motion is carried thank you
councilors item number nine uh Gore
District Council representation review
uh CH speak this
one yeah thanks your worship uh as the
report suggest every six years the
council must undertake uh a first
principles review of how uh it has
structured itself for electoral Purp
purposes um the criteria is laid out in
the local electoral act
2001 um and as my report suggest it
really looks at fundamental issues
around what size Council should be
assembled uh the number of wards uh the
number of elected at large if any um the
role of a community board and equality
ofes representation what they call fear
fear representation so that each elected
member serves an equal number of of
population plus a minus
10% um the over the years councils up
and down the country have
embraced uh a lot of different
initiatives to do their reviews and as I
mentioned also my report in
20067 2006 mainly the council had a
actual a dependent panel of members of
the public who went away and and
actually came up with a
recommendation uh which was a subject of
opposition um and ultimately was
appealed to the local government
commission and we got that current
structure which has been in place since
the 2007 elections um we have a proposal
from elections.com to do an independent
review um and as I said you give them a
report that uh
elections.com that's what they do they
run elections and know a lot about
electoral
models um but there is a cost it hasn't
been budgeted for um and I guess it
depends on how committed or exploratory
you want to be with your review as to
whether you go the independent way the
um el.com do want to hold workshops with
the council and community and they might
be particular Council might be hard to
find dates given got ltp um to attend to
early in next year so the alternative
and of course I was going to get the
former deputy chief executive re capable
to do this exercise because he had uh
done some fairly extensive reviews in
the South District but of course he's no
longer with us I've personally done this
a couple times before um could do do the
task but it would be focused um in terms
of coming to you with some a couple of
options and dispensing with pre
Community engagement to just get it out
there um out there for comment uh bear
in mind that um once the public receive
a proposal uh they can submit on
it can be heard before the council and
then they have um further appeal rights
to the local government commission if if
unhappy with what the council comes up
with and I'm emphasize that point
because you can go through all the
consultation uh you can come up with
what you think is a good model you put
it out there if you get an objector that
says I don't like this um and you choose
to not uphold that objection that person
has got the right to go to the
commission the commission will then
conduct it own uh denovo review um so
just given what's uh we have competing
both in terms of budgets but also just
workloads and finding time for workshops
uh there is there is an option of doing
it internally but if I was being
completely honest the best practice
option would be to have an external um
provider do the job for
you thank you Steve uh councilors
questions comments
uh
canc there was clearly some background
Preparatory work that needs to be done
um and and in terms of the list that's
there identification of communities of
interest um so before I lead on to what
I've got to say i' be interested in some
um feedback from the chief executive as
to how that is done um and is that
something that is really able to be
achieved without the use of uh further
Consultants through you
um you worship communities of interest
um it can be
either again as uh a deeper dive and
exploring it as you want want or it can
be um quite simple and
straightforward uh for example if you go
through a deep dive you might find that
the communities of Interest actually
extend beyond the current boundaries of
the gore District uh and that takes you
into a different place and
space um Community interest uh hither to
tend to be reasonably obvious in regard
to the gore Township
and you might and in the past the G
Township has been divided into ws and
was quickly Amalgamated into One
Singular
Community Mata has its own defined
community of interest and then you have
rural areas uh comprised of currently
Wards and
um and some small townships um but in
previous times if you look at for examp
for example certain key retailing
outlets in the
gore area you look at health services
and how they are provided and funded you
may come up with a completely different
answer I say extends well beyond the the
boundaries of the G District which I've
personally always known that
artificially compa but how far do you go
that's really a question to be answered
by the
um AUST
Gathering which um leads me um I guess
to my key Point
um that the chief executive made the
comment that he would come to us with
several options and I actually see it
the other way around um I believe that
as councilors we should be providing to
you several options to actually report
back on and it may well be the the um uh
what's what's the word that we've got
here the wards may not be determined
solely on a geographical basis a spatial
basis um but actually on an activities
based um one and and I know in
conversations I've had with people
around the table including his worship
that um urban areas might be for example
um a ward in terms of um possibly G mat
and even some of smaller townships being
considered having the same
characteristics um and there are a
number of things that are there listed
in the report in terms of we've got to
go back to First principles not only in
terms of the wards that we have but also
in terms of the role of the community
board and I'm I'm an advocate for
actually if it is practical to extend
the role of the community board um but
again we've got to go back to First
principles with the community board in
terms of is it fulfilling its um
initial function a bit like the youth
Council has it actually strayed from
what was intended um so um I guess my
key point is that I would like to see a
politically lead um uh approach to this
and um I feel that as elected
representatives we will have a greater
influence on what is presented if we
actually do it in house rather than the
use of external um consult
thank
you thank you councelor C
Phillips thank you wish uh we're going
to probably get some radical change with
everybody's ideas around the council
table because I'd like to drop it for 10
to five for a start off because there's
too many of us um well when you think
about point of order I think there 12 of
us
sorry there's always going to be a mirr
anyway so from ter missing a couple of
yeah so so um like when you think about
there's one in 5,000 one C of 5,000 in
the IC and one in 1500 for so just a
just a a radical change but as far as as
far as my representation for the Mata
Ward the community board itself I
wouldn't be able to do my job without
them and and I think it's it's a
representative of of your own community
and what you do and
um yeah it's going to be some
interesting
conversation thank you
counselor any further
comments uh councelor McKenzie then
councelor
re just one um through your worship the
cost of getting it done
independently any
ideas oh it's already there thank
you thank you counselor councelor
read actually my point was to the cost
and if we can save the community
$22,000 for a report disperss plus
dispersements yes um which are who knows
what that's going to cost um I think if
we can work together to give the chief
executive some
um ideas to be going forward um I'd like
to thank him for offering his services
to do
that thank you councelor councelor
Fraser uh thank you I had $20,000
written down here plus just
just um whatever that would be it's just
astronomic and again love to thank the
chief executive for offering his
Services thank you counselor uh I just
had a question um with this offer that's
on the table uh what's the latest we can
move forward with that if we were to to
change options down the line
three wish off the top of my head
probably March at a pinch because the
model preferred by the external provider
provides for um cons pre model
development workshops with the council
and the community to get some feedback
um and I'm thinking that to to load
those in and still come up with a firm
proposal that must be published by the
8th of September off top Mye next year
I'd say March um otherwise their
preferred process would be difficult to
achieve in their
timeline thank you for that Steve I
guess the reason why I was asking is uh
if we can meet and have that
conversation in the early New Year it
means if we do uh for whatever reason
can't agree around the table um it
always leaves us as a backup um until
March
um if we've really got very radical
different views moving
forward to move to 10 and then to five
or do we have a recommendation floating
around would you like me to read one
out when so a workshop to a politically
lead Workshop in the early New Year um
with the assistant of the chief
executive um to try and come up with a
uh fish plan to consult
on that Susan cool could I have a m for
that motion cancel guine seby councelor
mcdell I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried thank you
councilors number 10 in uh on page 89
financial report for 31 October 2023 I
see that La is not here so Steve talk to
it happy to Y you're everyone
today yeah thanks you worship uh
unfortunately Lae is not with us today
um and so I've been um tossed the ball
uh to to run with um look in in summary
we the the finance staff pretty um happy
and comfortable where we've landed for
the first four months uh for the year
ending so up until 31 October uh but
there are some a couple of of pressure
points uh as listed in in the
introduction to the actual financial
report um District plan is probably the
major area of concern in Rel relation to
cost control uh but it's just the nature
of the Beast um District plans are
notoriously resource hungry and
increasingly complex to prepare um I
have been involved on the periphery of
two or three other District plans uh one
on this Council and one at North and I
just see that the the evolution
of Juris Prudence in this planning area
means that you the council's not really
um able to just put together a bunch of
rules like in the old days it now needs
to have good solid evidence to support
its thinking and that usually results in
commissioning of um a range of experts
to actually inform uh the structure of
the plan so that's one that um is
difficult to predict in terms of quantum
but as I said um is alluded to in the
report U ultimately well it doesn't
allude to the report but I should
emphasize that the district Plan cost
will be capitalized in in terms of uh
put into a loan because the uh expected
benefit of the document will run for
approximately 15 years and the idea is
that then that loan would then be
retired over that period of time um
there are some other
um points of of uh just management and
Parks reserves there's been some uh a
couple of two or three expensive repairs
on Machinery which just um
disproportionately Elevate the experence
of this time of the year uh and this I'm
not having a chance to talk one one of
the staff in finance but there was an
incorrect treatment of the irrigation
costs at the showr which should be
capitalized again and not put into
operation so that's that's be worked out
work through as well but overall um sta
cost down um we we we're thinking we're
we're tracking not too badly for the
first four months
um um pinch points tend to be a bit more
obvious and need to be watched a lot
more closely generally in the November
to February period where a lot of our
spending starts to take place in the
height of the
um not just a construction season but
just a good weather where you get things
done thank you Steve uh councilors
questions uh councelor
mcdell yeah thank thank you Steve for
the explanation on Parks and reserves
because that was a an item I had marked
down here as a uh major unfavorable
variance in an operation that we can
actually control a lot B uh control and
it's uh the other thing is there in the
in the report there's a lot of timing
issues there and the mix of capital
projects and the mistiming so it's it's
you have to really read very carefully
through it and work work your way
through it to see where the unders and
overs occur but thank you for the
report thank you
councelor
cancor Dixon thank you worship um just a
question I was just wondering regarding
the rates are there what percentage of
the rates have been unpaid this
year in this current
year just um through worship uh I don't
have it my fingertips but um
the last quarters collection was
generally On a par with previous so it's
we we generally get to around about 96
97%
collection um there are a handful of
properties that um we are working
through in terms of failure to pay and
what have you but uh at this point in
time it hasn't presented at this stage
as being um despite the the the the cost
of living um hasn't presented itself as
being extraordinary different from
previous years in terms of we've got a a
pretty good collection rate around that
96% uh if you sift through the audit and
risk minutes there as well it's got a
age deiters report there too um which
has the breakdown of of where we're at
in terms of collections uh councelor McD
that that was a that point I was going
to make that there was no major change
in the with the order and risk when we
looked at the the
datas uh looking at it here it's
2.12 uh outstanding
rates uh oh that's for the 2023 yeah it
it'll be it'll be in there somewhere so
have
a yeah so 2
2.12% okay thank you I just thought it's
been a hard year for some people and
just interested thank
you uh canc go on just noted the
building department are down 45,000 is
there Trend usually there a rush before
Christmas and the shut off dates been
cut has the trend still down or is it
sort of leveled
off through you worship uh I spoke with
Russell P building control me just uh
well been speaking three times in last
week uh it has there has been an upswing
uh pre- Christmas not to the same kind
of tsunami that they normally get but
it's um the the the quiet period has uh
left us and also the same the feedback
has come from the planning people as
well so I
think my gut feel is that the election
and the formation of a new government
has possibly prompted people to feel a
little bit more confident about their
movements moving
forward thank you councel and thank you
Steve any further
questions I just had one I'm not sure if
you be able to answer this but the
capital expenditure by Department
elected members what's what's capital
expenditure um by elected
members through your worship that'll be
off the top of the head uh Furniture um
TV that type of stuff you know uh um
computers yeah that's I know it's
reasonably humble but that all comes
into that asset purchases which is which
are part of capital
expend no that makes sense thank you for
that uh councel
Dixon thank you wish um just a question
for the CEO is there any way we can pull
back the district plan consultant
funding I mean the longer we draw it out
the more it's going to cost and I think
um it's becoming we're over budget now I
can see it going a lot further over
budget in the
future uh through you your worship very
hard
because uh it's
a um we're now right in the the pointy
end of the district plan we're about to
um the new year there will be a summary
of submissions received be notified and
inviting cross submissions on that and
then we're into hearings and then you
got specialist planning staff to
actually do reports uh for the hearing
Commissioners um it's not something that
you can economize on or minimize it's
it's it's now driven by the the
submissions that we have um and it's
like any quasi legal process once you're
in it
you you really are just Duty bound to to
work your way through it um what I can
say however uh because you know some
councils they have their District plans
forever and environment Court being
challenged or parts there of um I've
just had only seen a summary of the
submissions but um from what I could see
through my um nonplanning eyes uh but
legal eyes as I thought well this
doesn't appear to be too what I called
legal showstoppers here that would that
with good processes in place good advice
uh hopefully that we will get at the end
of around about a Year's worth of
hearings we'll get a a finally adopted
District plan hopefully without the
prospect of appeals because if you get
appeals then you're in the environment
Court then you law you got lawyers and
then um the cost are further get away
are you so investing at the front end of
the process could save you a lot of
costs Downstream at towards the end of
the process I'm sorry I can't give you
more um promising answer
that thank you T uh any further
questions I just want to than uh L and
the the finance team for this report um
it's it's really valuable information is
really good to have in front of us um I
know we've talked about it before but is
there a frequency to when we should be
expecting these reports going
forward absolutely you worship now we've
got our new um reporting software this
will be on a monthly basis to for
Council fantastic I think that'll be
very pleasing for counselors to
hear uh and with that c up get a mover
that the report be received uh councelor
mcell seconded by councelor Fraser I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say I and against the motion is
carried 11 page 100 uh Great South
request for an increase increase in Co
funding uh would Steve like to talk to
this
one yeah thanks your worship um it's
never easy when you're preparing a
budget uh for the next year and then
you're starting with some requests for
increased cont
contributions um and at first blush you
look at the percentage you think gee
that's getting up there but in terms of
quantum um it's not necessarily such a a
huge amount to to ask uh to put aside uh
although every extra is going to count
in the forthcoming estimates that we do
uh early in the new year uh but looking
at Great South and
um and how it's performed over the last
two or three years it really is on the
the cusp of um trying to breaking
through and
using uh the momentum that it has to
date to capitalize on opportunities um
and I referred like for example
aquaculture within the new government um
one of
the frustrations and sometimes
distractions with uh Regional Economic
Development agencies is that uh a lot of
the participant funders will say well
what what's in it for me and there is a
degree of faith in this faith in terms
of what's in it for the region um and
having a an effective Regional Economic
Development agency I think will be very
important in actually engaging with the
government and to be to be frank over
the
last 10 or 15 years successive
governments have said we want to talk to
the regional we want to want to have a
regional organization to converse with
as opposed to every Council having its
own little Economic Development um so um
this is just the cost of living um that
we are you now seeing the the the brunt
off uh with these increas costs um but
on balance I couldn't
see uh a reason not to give you a
positive
recommendation yes uh the organization
is has invested in space operations yes
there's an increase in Revenue but as
the chair I thought made it very clear
in the workshop with counselors recently
made a point that look they need to be
able to um use those Reven Ed to
actually grow the business and anyone
who's been in business will know that
quite often it's it's re reinvesting to
grow the business to get it to a scale
where you can reap rewards and I guess
space Ops is in is in that growing phase
uh so hence that's why Great South is
saying we would like to reinvest those
revenues as opposed to asking us to uh
to to grab them off space Ops and avoid
uh an increasing contributions from our
um key
shareholders uh but it's very much a
political matter you worship and it's
very much one I think of based on
Regional
Faith thank you Steve counselors any
questions uh councelor McKenzie then
councelor
Phillips I still class myself as being a
bit of a newbie but I ask the
question what benefit do we get from
being a part of Great South I know we
have shares in it Etc but what benefit
are we getting if it was a business
you'd be really looking at your return
on your investment wouldn't
you just an open question to anybody
that wants to
comment what is the benefit of being
part of Great
South I councelor Phillips have a okay
one thank you wor and you probably um
add on as well but uh the benefit for me
is that we don't have any ccos in their
in their District right and I believe
that being part of Great South is a
investment in long term it's not an
investment for short term and we've seen
uh great things from Great South uh in
their SpaceX operation and while we're
not seeing any returns I look at it as a
future for the for the for the Youth
that are coming through in their
District um
I think uh it might be prudent perhaps
then that we have
a then come up and and give us a
demonstration on on uh space Ops and and
show them show everybody around the
table what what they've done um what
it's capable of in where in the world
everybody the it comes from
so um
and yeah the the other stuff the
agriculture I think it's going to be a
big thing in Southland and I think we
need to be part of that um and if you're
not in the ground it's like it's like
most companies if you're not in the
ground starting up of it you miss
out uh you're in there for the Long Haul
and I think uh that's probably the only
thing that we've got to say to ourselves
that wearing it for the long and we're
we're doing it for the future of the
district really of a district
thank you councel I'll just jump in
before I go to councelor Fraser um
totally agree with with those statements
uh I guess the big piece of work that
just been finished Beyond 2025 um where
the the cycle um cycle assessment done
recently uh we had the tourism
assessment just recently
released um they've done some work on
future for local government for us um
the list goes on and on I seem to be
going to great stuff things quite a
often um so I guess it's just I need to
do a better job of exposing that to the
rest of the counselors to to see the
work I'm totally agree with councelor
Phillips if you do get the chance to go
down to space Ops um I know that me and
Council Stringer went down at the the
beginning of our term and it's very
impressive to go and see the satellites
down there and just the the work that
they're doing um so they're working with
with big organizations like U SpaceX and
and your Googles and Microsoft and
things like that to to contact servers
and satellites so um it's a pretty
awesome stuff um for little corner of
the world um but yes the the benefit to
us uh is sometimes hard to see but also
that's Quantified and uh the funding
that we give so we give a very small
portion um just over what was it 260,000
if it's approved today uh compared to
the the million uh that each of the
bigger councils give um so we get quite
a bit of benefit for for not a whole
huge amount of input councelor
f um I must missed netive today
um I'm not saying pull away from Great
South um I appreciated them coming in
giving us sort of an explanation as to
around with the O plant and a few other
things like that but um in a recent
document Council ofal pointed out how
many times GA was mentioned in that
document uh where Bluff was mentioned
probably twice the amount of times um
space Ops great idea but reinvestment is
a very quick way we want to reinvest
they didn't actually say what they
wanted to do just we're just going to
reinvest
we've got people in this town who are
struggling to pay the rent pay the bill
pay the power and we've got this big
organization that has actually let us
down this year without a proper
explanation that I'm I'm not supportive
actually I'm I'm continuing a funding
yes I've got no problem but no
more fair point councilor
Fraser uh counc dexon then Council
Stringer thank you wishop I think um we
have a lack of representation at a
higher level in
government now and I think Great South
helps to fill that role because we do
need economic development in Southland
and that that actually is affects us as
well in the gore District but like
councelor Fraser I would like to and
councel hell I'd like to see more of
this funding coming to G District
Council thank you councelor councelor
Stringer thank you worship um yeah I'd
like to back what Andy has um said
before me there um I would also like to
see whether they can divest some of
their Investments and what they've put
in the things that haven't worked out
and to fund that separate to fund that
shortfall um and um through your worship
is the this an unbudgeted expense going
forward or is this something we're
budgeting for thank you so correct me if
I'm wrong Steve but this will have to be
worked into our longterm plan so this
will go as part of our overall budget
the increase the increase yeah
yeah uh just also a bit of extra
information for for counselors who may
not be aware uh Great South is changing
the way that they do things as well so
the the typical way they've done it as a
statement of intent every year and an
increasing uh report like this coming to
council every year for an increase in
funding they're changing it to a
three-year cycle in line with our
long-term plans as well so they'll
actually give a lot more clarity for the
funding model that they need for three
years rather than just the one year so
moving forward will get a much bigger
overview of those those wider
discussions of we actually need to
divest from space Ops and give us a
little bit more leeway moving forward so
that's a that's a quite a big change
that's happening at Great South but
we'll ultimately lock in with our
long-term plan a whole lot better um so
that we don't go through this um regar
roll every year of having to increase
funding um it'll just be in line with
our
budgets uh councilor Reed thank you Mr
Mayor um just a question for the CEO as
shareholders in great s are we any under
uh any legal obligation
to um meet these increased
demands or increase
costs
um through worship no strictly no this
is discretionary in terms of as a
request by the um the the organization
fund for extra funding uh and they
believe that their reserves should only
be um drawn down to a certain level but
no you're not legally obliged um you are
legally obliged to carry on with the
current level of funding and any move
not that has been mentioned tonight to
um exit the organization uh off the top
my head to about one year's
notice any further questions comments
about councel
gine yeah Al we bit disappointed in the
um adventure of the oat Factory um very
much disappointed but um also they
probably should sell the sh holding down
now that it's
moved um but they probably won't and
they'll probably miss the boat there too
but the other thing I was really
disappointed in was in the um tourism
brocher there was no mention of the
field days in our district um and like
Keith said there was quite a few things
missing and we need to if we do stay
with the Great South we need to be make
sure we are put up front even if we
minority
shareholder those things are important
and they invented structure for all of
Southland and Beyond and um if they're
not mentioned well I don't think they're
thinking about us we're just a we bit
far away or the state size where we had
have a discount because we're of had
distance we're not at the back door
every day but I do agree with glenis and
uh that we do need um a front for
central government and this is probably
the most important bit for Great South
and um but we need to watch that we
don't miss
out well well counselor gine uh just on
that that she holding that the intention
I believe is to is to withdraw it's just
actually waiting for a bit of value in
there but you're right there may never
be value there so yeah Fair assessment
uh councilor mcdonell and then counselor
uh
mcf we keep talking about
the long-term plan uh we keep adding
these things to it our rate increas is
just going to go through the roof so I
get regard Great South as a as a nice to
have not a necessity so I'll be voting
against giving them an increased funding
so that's the how I see
it thank you councelor councilor rer
mcf just worship a couple of comments
here um if we aren't with great South
who are we with
who's going to do our
work that's probably the question I'd
ask um if we don't uh second question be
through the CEO if we don't do the
increas in uh increasing funding the
allocation do we um well what are we
subject to what ramification are we
subject to as shareholders do we drop a
shareholding um we don't actually have
allocated shares um it's all on a uh a
dollar value isn't it across and we've
also got two of other subcomittees who
have already paid the increase I believe
sou District Council and
um who's the other one yeah three yeah
three have paid there so um just a
couple of things to think about when we
start looking at it uh and the other
thing that was alluded to was the fact
that um Regional Faith well faith is
something you can't
see and sometimes it's not tensionable
so
um I think that uh we have to have a
voice maybe it's the only voice we've
got so be very careful about um we know
that our costs are increasing too and we
have focused on a couple of things there
that haven't gone particularly well the
oats and the um and obviously spaces are
a big one um but yeah I don't think we
want to get left behind either um if
advances are coming so that's my
opinion
thank you coun I it's a valid point
actually is that if if we make this move
to not fund it and then we proceed down
the path of potentially withdrawing then
we completely miss out on those those
space up shareholdings and the in the
nzf as well um down the line get it's
incredibly complicated not that
complication should affect that but um
yeah I think we might miss out long term
I would agree Council re thank you I
don't think anybody around the table is
talking about withdrawing I I think
we're just looking closely at what um
that cost covers and where we go with it
um I don't think there's any suggestion
of that I know the aquaculture um
Venture that they've been working on
once that is in place um will be quite
beneficial to the entire
Province thank you councelor councelor
Fraser yeah I can care C I'm not saying
leave I'm just saying no to the extra
funding um um they
yeah Council H I'd like to move that the
council approve the request for the
increase in funding for great health
they set out there in the
agenda C second councelor Richard mcf uh
F the
debate councilor
McKenzie I
concur with SH um Carry On as we are but
I would vote against the increase
requested which I'll do thank you
councelor any
further Council
Phillips thanks you R I just want to um
remind everybody that when at the
workshop that um Great South were well
aware of a disappointment in what we've
seen so far and I think uh the chief
executive was there to to try and
improve it the other thing is that with
the four council is joined together we
have a greater chance of getting Central
funding for any big projects and they've
pointed that out and I think um for us
not to be uh on on side with great self
and then it means that if they ask for a
little bit more money that we should be
just thinking yeah we should be there
you know just have a think about
it thank you
Council any the
comments would you let your rer
reply no I think all said we
ready I will put the motion all those in
favor please say I I and
against one two three four five five
against five yeah five
against so the motion is carried would
you like those recorded as
against so it's councelor McKenzie
counselor Stringer councelor Gard
counselor Fraser and counselor
Mel thank you counselors that was an
interesting
one I think it it seems a pretty clear
message as to how tight funds are um for
for all councils at the moment uh item
number 12 uh page 110 treasury
management subcommittee uh pretty
straightforward uh there Steve any
comments on these draft terms of
reference uh councelor
Phillips uh no comment I know the
factors are more than happy with the
recommendations of the councilors and
the um the OB server and like to move
the
recommendation can I pleas have a second
councelor Fraser any further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you
counselors uh and now just the Urgent
late business oh sorry schedule of
meetings my apologies uh item
13 do we have any questions or comments
Steve just one your worship uh the
suggested date of 20 February 2024 for
the first council meeting could we
change that to 7 February 2024 because
20 February 2024 has been allocated for
an ltp
Workshop uh if my memory is correct is
that Whitey
day is it a
Monday
oh the 7th is a Wednesday so we'll be
doing it day after what day
okay oh yeah it is too
canc I see that there's an asset and
infrastructure meeting on the 5th of
March um which is also set down for a
council meeting to finalize the
long-term plan
documentation and I'm a little bit
worried that yet again we'll have
another one of these um all night
sessions um do we have to have them both
on the same
day um if I can just through your
worship I guess um at that time of year
there's going to be a lot of overlap
between what would normally apart from
the general capital projects um and
compliance updates that we we have going
through the committee on that 5th of
March um council meeting you're going to
have things like the um assets I mean
the infrastructure strategy you're also
going to have the lot of the activity
management plans um at that time also so
so there would be a bit of overlap
between what we would potentially have
on an agenda for assets and
infrastructure meeting and a council
meeting but acknowledg that there is um
some potential
uh stretching out of council's time
however that is going to be a uh
fundamental principle of the next three
months as we work through the long-term
plan um and that's something we're just
going to have to uh ride with I think
through that period
but
thank you for that
Jason uh councilor
Stringer if my um coun correct there's
31 meetings here can we just pick a
month with 31 days on it and we just
rock one out every
day thank you
counselor
any other further
questions just ask the just recognizing
there's only three Community well-being
meetings is the cheer comfortable with
that you worship I did question that why
there was only going to be three because
there's four assets and infrastructure
and policy and
Regulatory so you like four is there a
date that we can squeeze and I imagine
that it was pretty hard to fit hints why
there's only
three
how does the 10th of December sound
Council dexon 10th of December y so we
add it as
well everybody else happy with the
meeting schedule
there uh just as a bit of a I guess a
precursor um to to counselors
considering we'll be back uh so early
this year and won't have our regular uh
January period to catch our breath um I
will look at seeing whether we can gain
some flexibility in the July August
period next year um depending on how the
ltp goes um to to create some space for
counselors to take some time um because
I know that um people's holiday plans
may have been interrupted with the
business we have in in January so I just
wanted to flag that
early any further
comments uh councelor Phillips happy to
move second
by cancel Dixon I put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried minutes of the
Mota community board meeting councelor
Phillips uh thank you worship no nothing
to add just uh available for any
questions that might want to be
pondering but I will give you the
counselor some good news even though
it's not on here that the so up for MATA
today said I guess I Tri down there as
an order isn't
it I also think I saw a text from the
chair about the lottery Grant as well
coming through for Park is that correct
y that that that's great uh your worship
um we we G from another 300,000 to
finish off the project which is going to
give us um excellent um facility down in
for for the whole district for everyone
to come down and the thing is that when
we start getting our cycle walkway from
Gordon Mata everyone will come be able
to come down and play to the heart
contain mat the first class facility
that we have down there but I just like
i' like to um while I'm sitting here
thank the staff for all their hard work
in gaining that funding for us and you
know it's uh it's not only just an asset
for MATA but for the whole
District thank you Council it be pretty
cool to see once that's finished I
believe that's beginning the process uh
in the new year so the New Year if I'm
correct there uh Council
Dex thank you worship uh just a question
for councelor Phillips regarding the um
toilets there's been a lot of expense
there with them being vandalized and I
see there's some new um facilities going
in there is there any protection or
cameras or anything like that put in
there
to stop this sort of vandalism that's
happening um first of all I just like to
U thank the local police or in in the
district Conservatory in in um keeping a
um I handle on what's Happening down in
Mata and it's just a small group of
youths that are down there just creating
habit
um and we all know that uh when the
police hands are tied when they comes to
Youth and we've tried our best uh to the
point is that I've taken them myself and
made them do a bit of clean up and
Tiding up and some of the buildings that
they vandalized in
mat but um there is
cameras
and different variation points which
show good good
um um things that that shouldn't be seen
um and things that we need to see
so uh on the Redevelopment of tet park
that is that will be a priority to make
sure that the council's assets are in
safe
hands and uh once again the staff have
to put up with the situations about what
happens and uh I just like to thank them
for their dedication and resilience and
having to when they answer the phone
call saying I'm not again and it's it is
disappointing and it as I said it's just
a minority of
young uh male youths running around Mata
as a group
um I don't know what else to say except
for probably just try and show off their
manly PS probably I don't know but we're
doing our
best interesting description of yourself
there councelor
Phillip you've all seen my dance Gams on
the council thing so it's not and I just
put it down I just like to refer to the
point is that it was uh grippy carpet
and rough shoes I didn't have my smooth
shoes on that was
problem excuses excuses eh
uh any further questions comments could
I have a move the minutes received and
that the recommendation contained be
ratified councilor Philip second adby
councilor read I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I against the
motion is carried the counselors need a
moment just to read through the Urgent
late business there it's pretty
straightforward Bo um we do these fairly
often could I please have a mover that
the council appointment authorized
Britney Jackson to understate various
enforcement related duties in accordance
with the Local Government Act 2002
councilor phaser seconded by councelor
guine any further
questions I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you very
much I realized after I did my
introduction speech uh that I forgot to
thank the most important people who make
this ship run uh which is the staff so
thank you very much uh each and every
one of you uh for what you've had to put
up with this year um for keeping this
ship afloat um and for continuing to do
the work um despite what um may be
happening elsewhere so just a huge thank
you um for all of your great work
councelor
Phillips thank you wish uh I'd just like
to say on behalf of the council wishing
you yourself and your partner Merry
Christmas and um a safe trip wherever
you go around over Christmas and look
forward to uh some good discussion and
Robos for next year and wish you all the
best thank you counselor that means a
lot and yes Merry Christmas uh to all
the counselors um have a good uh break
some of those will be shorter than
others um but we will see you back in
January so really appreciate it with
that um
I will have a quick five minute break uh
and then we'll get into the in
commmittee stuff